you can be anyone even a good person
didn't need to tell you that in case
anyone had ever said different
i i had to open with that because that
line
legitimately choked me up and i was
deathly afraid that i was going gonna
forget to mention it like i forgot to
talk about the confirmation of loki
being bisexual in the previous episode
ah okay i should probably address that
briefly
i thought that was pretty well handled
for how it was done now
i have seen some criticism that it is
handled in such a way that is easily
removable
um in terms of re-editing it for
distribution elsewhere i'm sure that's
true
i for the time being i have accepted
that as a given
with disney that doesn't make it okay or
at the very least it doesn't mean
that it's something that we should
continue to be okay with but for right
now
while i'm still just waiting for more
flat out representation in mass media
at all i will take this with
mild complaint of pointing that stuff
out but i'm not going to say like don't
do this because this is more than we
were getting before
and i think keeping that that in mind
that it is
like basically just a line in one
conversation i
do think it was pretty well done now
much like
uh how i talk about uh my general
principle that bad representation is
better than good representation
that is so long as it moves forward
because it gives us a
starting point to improve and get better
so i'm kind of the same opinion of this
style of representation right now we
just need more of it
and then once we have that as long as it
continues to move forward to more
substantive and better integrated
representation instead of easily removed
one-off lines
then i don't mind it being this now as
long as we get something better later
cool cool so that was last episode me
catching up
now this one it's good
the some of the stuff well a fair amount
of the stuff like
i was not surprised by so like i called
i think back in the first episode that
the timekeepers weren't real
called that so that was a shot like can
i say though
what the scene with the time keepers i
had to put the captions on
because like i understand they were
trying to make them sound
impressive or alien or whatever but like
i couldn't understand a damn thing they
said
i had to put captions on that was
annoying i shouldn't have to do that
um that said okay
um this was cool there's a line i'm not
gonna
say where it is because that's a
discussion for later but there is a line
that
loki says uh whereas is this hell
and i ha and uh i i actually i
backed up that moment because i wanted
to check something else the way i have
my captions set
is if i don't have them set
automatically which i had to do for the
time keepers then if i hit the little
repeat function
it backs it up about 10 15 seconds and
puts the captions on
basically just in case uh the reason i'm
backing it up was because i didn't
understand what was said
that wasn't the reason i backed up this
moment but i noticed that in the
captioning
hell only had one l the way the proper
norse hell would be
like i might be
uh like the only person who doesn't keep
captions on all the time who may have
caught that
and i thought that was really cool props
to the captioning people well i would
i would say probably props to the script
because it was probably written like
that in the script and then when it was
captioned it was
transposed so like tiny touch most
people will never know
i know and it made me smile i have been
diverting
immediately right off the bat not even
really talking about the main plot okay
let's uh let's start to do that then so
they did kind of do what i was a little
bit afraid of in terms of
um fairly easily like narratively easily
resolving the fact that loki and silvie
were
on a planet and about to die my
criticism of the cliffhanger ending of
the previous one
still kind of stands that said it was
not nearly as egregious as i was
expecting it to be
because it doesn't happen immediately
and more importantly
we get time with the two of them
together sort of giving weight to the
moment
and we get a little bit more insight
into silvie and
another thing i was right about that
they plucked her young
and they do account for the fact that
like there was probably some deviation
going on with her already up to that
point
but things like for instance whatever
the cause
for her being a girl whether that was
from birth and that was the initial
deviation or whether that was
something she chose to do we don't know
i kind of hope we don't find out
honestly i don't i don't actually want
it
necessarily confirmed that sylvie
was at some previous point from the
young girl that we see
originally male because it doesn't
matter
she's a woman either way so i
actually kind of hope they don't confirm
that one way or the other
um and i might be alone on that but
that's me
but we see her young and it does get
stated in dialogue that
you know basically her continued exist
individual things she did
weren't necessarily a big deal but um
the implication seems to be that her
continued existence
being slightly different for long enough
caused enough of a deviation that they
finally had to deal with her
um although she she asks
you know about what was the specific
thing that i
did and uh
rev ravello uh the judge i'm just gonna
say the judge i like i can never
remember her name properly
um you know says her i don't remember
and you don't
know if that's true or if she's just
messing with sylvie but
it it may not that's either going to be
something that they come back to and the
whole plot hinges on or it actually
doesn't matter and they're just going to
move past it
we'll see as things continue to pan out
the they did a good job like
i'll give you a warning before i get to
the big spoiler stuff about the very end
but like at this point four episodes in
i have to talk about core concepts that
are going on here so this is kind of
spoilery regardless
um spoiler free version ish
uh short spoilers i kind of already said
it's good
it's good it continues to be good i'm
excited for more
um this this was a solid pickup from the
previous one it's picked up momentum
again i'm here for it cool
so i'm gonna talk much more freely now
again i'll give the head up
head up heads up before i do the big big
spoilers
uh towards the end so when
we are watching the characters
involved sort of come to realize the
truth of sylvie's words that
they are that the entire tva
is staffed with variants who have
had that reality hidden and removed from
them
that's here's the thing here's why i
want to single that out because as a
plot point like that's not original
people who seem to be decent people
working for an organization they don't
realize is
evil you know turning on that
organization very standard
as far as any kind of plot with an
organization like the tva goes
however the thing is a lot of
um films or tv shows
do that too quickly and it doesn't feel
earned and it can oftentimes feel like
the plot just needs them to change sides
so they just do
and they just turn on a dime against
something that we have seen them very
committed to
up to this point and it sometimes you go
i don't think i
buy it like you rushed they they rushed
to that conclusion
it's upending too much of their world
that they would just leap there and go
like
ah this is my new truth i'm like but
that doesn't really happen here
um and we and they managed to pull it
off with two characters
so with mobius we've already seen him
like asking little questions and like
innocuously like back to the i think
second episode um when he's talking with
the judge
and he mentions offhandedly that he's
never met the time keepers and he
i don't get the feeling there that he's
bringing that up because he's
questioning his
place in this or his job at the tv area
or anything it's like but that's just
the kind of guy he is he's just kind of
note these things and
he's not questioning them yet so later
after talking with loki and loki
implanting this idea that they are all
variants
i he just strikes me as the kind of guy
to roll back through
in his head all the little things
that he'd noticed but hadn't examined
all the little questions he would ask
that would get brushed
off and he didn't think to question why
they were getting brushed off
now there's a context for it so he's the
kind of character that i totally buy
that with
now with the other b 15
um the sort of the lieutenant
style person who we've we've seen a fair
bit with her it's a little bit different
for
for her because she's a much more
um at least as she's been presented
emotionally driven character you know
very committed but very
like she see she's always seemed to have
an emotional investment in the mission
whereas
mobius was much more analytical so for
her
they rooted the turn much more in
emotion and in her sense of
betrayal and in her being emotionally
knotted up
by finding out from sylvia what's going
on and
things that have been happening and what
happened to c20
i feel like there's an implied
relationship between b15 and c20
um i don't know if they'll confirm that
like that was just a vibe i got
that that's me so um they managed to
successfully pay off the
working for the villainous organization
turn you know face turn
uh into becoming you know a good guy
question mark or at least fighting
against that organization
well twice by two different methods one
with the analytical character that fell
earned one with a more emotional
character that felt earned i'd
i i wanted to highlight that because
it's something i've seen done uh
poorly so often i'm impressed they did
it well twice
in the same episode tom hiddleston
gets some really good stuff especially
when he's stuck in the loop
with uh sif mad at him and yelling at
him and hitting him
and like initially he's kind of brushed
it off but then it just keeps happening
over and over and over again you can see
it wearing on him
he he plays the weight
of these things really really well as
they just sort of slowly weigh him
down over time and owen wilson also does
some
really good work in here again it's not
always
easy to be able to act in a way where
you feel like you can
see the wheels turning in their head um
it was something honestly that robert
towney jr was really good at and it's
part of why he was so good at playing
tony stark
because you bought that he was actually
that smart because you thought he would
do these looks and these
notions and like all these little things
in his performance like you felt like
you were
seeing the thought process happening
even if you couldn't necessarily keep up
with it
and i and i got a little bit of that
same thing from owen wilson and this
as he was sort of doing his turn his
face turn
so that was that was all
well done good stuff um more
legitimately spoilery stuff now
the pruning of mobius was sad
especially because it came so soon after
him delivering that line that i opened
with and i liked
so much um that said there's gonna be an
asterisk on that but that's like
the big spoiler uh so we'll save that
stick a pin on it we'll come back to it
so
but that that could have felt that felt
a little emotionally manipulative
but in a way that i think worked i it's
it's often just
a derogatory thing to say oh that was an
emotionally manipulative moment look
any narrative that's trying to make you
feel something's gonna be emotionally
manipulative it's trying to manipulate
you in such a way to feel certain things
at certain times
it just is it's just a question of
whether it does it poorly
and i think this was a case where i i
could
see the the hand of the writers a little
bit more than was probably ideal but i
do think the moment still
worked overall for the most part um
so let's get to the
tail end here and the bigger spoiler
stuff
so we have this fight
loki and sylvie fighting these
tva agents with the time keepers looking
on yeah the timekeepers aren't real
again
called that so i kind of i
on multiple levels when loki
the loki we came in and started with tom
hiddleston got pruned
by the judge i loved that
on multiple levels one
it cut him off before he confessed his
love to sylvie and not that i have an
inherent automatic problem with that
but that moment was starting to
exemplify
why i don't like romantic subplots
in stories that aren't that aren't built
to be
romances uh first and foremost because
it felt like they were stopping the
entire scene dead
to have this romantic moment so i was
kind of happy to have it be cut off
um it reminded me a little bit of when
uh the tenth doctor was cut off right
before confirming his love for rose
tyler
and much like that moment it's hard to
imagine that loki was going to say
anything
other than i love you i'm in love with
you whatever it might
be but i still like that you didn't make
me watch him
say that cause like all respect to
shippers
i don't care i i just don't
so like for me this was well balanced
because it was enough of it there to
like
give people like yes if you think this
is what's going on it's definitely
what's going on but then for people like
me it's like but we're not gonna make
you watch
then sit through the whole thing uh
while we stop the momentum dead in order
to do this we'll we'll pause it briefly
and then we'll keep going i'm like oh
okay
i can deal with that and then just the
balls
the cojones to kill that loki
and leave us with sylvie
and and i know some of you are gonna run
to the comments i i did see the post
credits i'll come back to it
i'm talking about in the moment when it
happened that was ballsy i was like oh
oh bold
and in that moment it made a lot of
sense because
if if they don't want to reintegrate
or if either he doesn't want to do it or
it doesn't make sense from uh
from whatever major stories they're
building in the films of the mcu if it
doesn't make sense to bring this loki
back
leaving us with this one who could
theoretically just
bounce around the um the disney plus
shows a bit
that that makes sense from uh sort of
managing the brand kind of thing
um and it just seemed like a really bold
move to give
her center stage in theory uh for the
last two episodes
then of course we got the post credits
which i'm a i'm a little i'm
of two minds on because on the one hand
it does kind of immediately undercut
the very bold move of killing
the male loki that having been said if
they were going to do this it was better
to do it as a mid
post credits thing rather than wait a
week and do it next time because
that would have left us in a situation
where i i don't know about anybody else
but i would have spent the whole week
thinking of all the possibilities of
just a female
loki show and then i would have come in
next week and they would have gone oh no
no no he's still here and i would be
oh god's sake so like accepting as a
given that he wasn't actually dead
better to reveal it here the way that
they did than to hold off on it on a
week
i think that would have been worse at
least in terms of managing audience
expectations and a response
and so it it does undercut that and it
does remove kind of
some of the boldness of
you know what i thought they were going
to do and that was a little bit
disappointing
and i i'm sure some people are going to
go well you must have known he was going
to come back because like we've seen
shots of loki that haven't shown up in
the show yet like with the vote loki pin
and all that like yeah but
in my mind that was sylvie running into
other variant loki's just not just not
this one
and um so i like i i had that covered
but anyways
that's me talking about what i thought
we were gonna have it's not what we do
let's talk about what we do have
so while i don't like that it undercuts
and sort of it
it's one of those situations where uh
and i bring this up from time to time
what the show pretended it was doing
was actually a little bit more
interesting to me than what it appears
to
actually be doing that said what it is
actually doing is still
interesting so it's not as big a gap as
the worst offenders of this kind of
thing can
be um for me like a really good example
of doing that badly is the first season
of umbrella academy
where particularly with the character
vanya what the setup was
for what her character's deal was i
found
way more interesting than the later
reveals of what was actually going on
like i find this way more generic and
way less interesting than what
the cover story was and so like that's
that's the far end of like
annoying me here like the gap between
what i
what you know my interest in what you
were gonna do versus what you are doing
it's a smaller gap but there's still a
gap but
we get all these other variant loki's
and there's richard e grant
finally i pretty much everybody called
that he was going to be some form of
old loki and i love that he's like in
classic friggin
60s you know the event the
uh original time that the avengers came
together
to fight loki looking outfit like
love that and we've got little kid loki
and like
there was a bunch going on there so i
i had kind of wondered are we going to
see more variants than self
sylvie and clearly now we are we got
them on mass i'll be curious to see how
this goes
forward also like i i don't think i ever
said this but i did have the notion
early on like
does the pruning just kill them because
that seems a little uninteresting and
part of me in the back of my head had
wondered is there something else going
on
i think i that's a holdover from doctor
who where it's not uncommon for
disintegration to secretly be
teleportation or what have you
so um that said that also gives us the
opportunity to possibly bring back
mobius
and i'd be uh i'd be down for that and
um i'm i'm definitely intrigued and
curious to see where this goes
the one last thing i want to bring up
i've seen a lot of speculation about
who's really behind the time keepers and
i know we're going to get some kind of
answer at my heart i don't care i care
about a a
strong resolution to the story and that
for me at least is not dependent on the
reveal of what's really going on
there's a lot of speculation that it's
going to end up being kang the conqueror
i kind
it like it would fit it would make sense
especially given that the judge
character
is tied to him because she is a
character from the comics
but that having been said i
kind of don't want that to happen
because we already know kang's going to
be the villain in the third ant-man and
so that makes this
feel more like a setup um or at least
the tail end of it potentially more like
a setup for other things in the mcu and
i'm just i'm getting
worried about these things becoming too
interdependent on each other
so that it's distinctly possible i'm not
saying it's not happening i'm just
saying i kind of hope it doesn't
but we'll see we'll keep an eye on that
um but for right now we're going to wrap
it up if you liked this video i hope
you'll
give me a like and if you have any
thoughts leave them down in the comments
and let's talk about it if you
love what i do consider supporting me on
patreon that is how i pay my bills and
keep this whole operation up and running
rewards at every tier etc etc check them
out
but you don't have to do any of it
because at the end of the day
you're the council i just run the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you um
[Music]